هذا يشبه الدراما العلمية أعني
القصة ، لذلك هناك هذه العينات مأخوذة
في مارس من عام 2020. يتم إتاحتها بشكل متقطع
للباحثين للنظر في
معظمهم يقولون ، نعم ، لقد
نظرنا إلى هذه العينات المأخوذة من هذا
الجرح على المأكولات البحرية  السوق ولا يوجد
دليل على أي شيء
بخلاف وجود فيروس كورونا هناك كما
كان هناك في الكثير من الأماكن في ووهان فجأة في
الأسبوع الماضي فقط ،
تظهر العينات على الخادم مرة أخرى وقد حصلت على
هؤلاء الباحثين في جميع أنحاء البلاد الذين
هم  يضربون التحديث باستمرار لمعرفة ما إذا كانت
هناك أي بيانات جديدة على هذه الخوادم
ويقولون حسنًا ، نعم ، ظهرت هذه البيانات الجديدة ،
لذا قاموا بتنزيلها بسرعة
وما وجدوه كان هذا في العينات
التي كانت إيجابية في السابق لـ
covid-19 ، ورأوا أيضًا أن هناك  كان
وجود الحمض النووي لهذا الحيوان في تلك
العينات وكذلك ذلك الحيوان كما
أشرت إلى أن كلب الراكون هو نوع من
الحيوانات معروف بقدرته على حمل
فيروسات كورونا وربما نقلها ،
وهذا ما نعرفه الآن أنه
يوجد حمض نووي للحيوان  اختلط الحمض النووي المرغوب فيه
داخل سوق المأكولات البحرية الجرح في مارس
2020 ، فهو ليس رصاصة فضية
لا يجيب على هذا بالتأكيد ولكن
لأن ما تحتاج إلى معرفته
سيكون في حيوان مصاب فعليًا ، فهذا
ليس حيوانًا مصابًا بالفعل.
نحتاج أيضًا إلى معرفة الجدول الزمني الذي يعني أنه من
الممكن أن يكون البشر قد جلبوا
الفيروس إلى السوق وأن
كلاب الراكون أصيبت بالعدوى من قبل البشر ، فمن
الممكن ، لذا من المثير للاهتمام حقًا ولكن
ليس نهائيًا ، كما تعلم ، قد تقول جيدًا
لماذا هذه البيانات هكذا  من الصعب أن
نتذكر نوع السرد من
الحكومة الصينية في الوقت الحالي هو أن
الجراثيم التي يقولون إنها نشأت في
الولايات المتحدة في ماريلاند في مختبر للجيش ، لذلك
هناك الكثير من الأسباب التي تجعل هذه البيانات التي
أعتقد أنها كانت مخفية نوعًا ما أو على
الأقل مكبوتة